foreign
Chris is with us Chris is in
Hendersonville Tennessee hi Chris how
are you
I'm good Dave how about yourself better
than I deserve what's up
well I I I call you with I feel like
it's a good problem to have we uh me and
my wife we've been married uh three
months now or so we have a two-year-old
daughter I opened a business about going
on about one calendar a year ago and I
mean it's uh I'm I mean I'm making more
money than I would ever thought possible
good for you my question for you is I
have you know I've only got really three
debts I have a car 65 000 in a car for
her I have a vehicle myself 33 000 when
I own it and we have a house uh 405 000
out on the house the only catch on the
house is being self-employed the house
is a 5-1-armed mortgage at current
current rate is 4.25 we bought it about
uh actually right when we got married we
got married and moved into our house uh
so we're three months into the house
um my question what do you make
uh my wife makes about 55 000 I make
about 410 000 now why do you still have
the card debt
well here my well so here's my thing the
first year that I was in business uh uh
you know I bought equipment I bought
things to help my business pay for it
cash and the rest of it I was just
Redneck Rich we went out to fancy
dinners we went everywhere we bought
everything 400
000 worth yeah well not I mean I have
about 60 000 in savings you're saying
400 000 was your profit on the business
last year that you paid taxes on no well
yes uh 400 000 was my income I paid all
I have overhead now is fuel and you know
that's taxes I'm a saying I'm a single
employee I don't have an employee's or
anything okay all right so so how much
money do you have any money
yeah I've got about about 60 000 give or
take in the bank sitting there yeah pay
off her car today
okay and then go pay off the other one
or pay off the 33 000 car today and then
go pay hers off next month
okay my my question essentially was do I
being self-employed uh make I make very
good money now I feel do I throw
everything that I have at the mortgage
being a five one or do I kind of pay it
normal or pay it a little hard and put
money in the bank and then it be towards
the end of the five one pay it off real
hard and that way if there is any sort
of a recession not huge I mean how
projectable how predictable stable do
you think this income stream is
it may drop down to 220 ish you know
about half but I mean that's still great
money I feel but I'm in the concrete
business so I mean they're as long as
there's still some sort of construction
we still are going to be doing work okay
wow
and you're again I'm going to verify
because I want to make sure I've got
your business Acumen straight you're
saying this 400 is taxable income that
you paid taxes on not like about 1800 a
day it's not your groceries it's not
your growth 1800 a day is your gross
revenue
yeah gross you have business expenses
out of that what is your net profit
uh I'll literally only pay fuel Fuel and
taxes is what I pay per day and then the
rest is profit for me okay
all right wow that's wonderful okay so
because whatever the equipment is
involved you've already paid for it and
so it's no longer yeah
or there or whatever on that but nothing
major okay yeah the first year was
paying the first year I mean the
equipment's 100 and 150 000 okay here's
what I want you to do all right you
you've
explain this beautifully and Ken I think
he's analyzed it well and that um he
feels like he uh uh just reached up and
got the gold ring you know I mean and
it's almost surprising to you that
you're making this kind of money I hear
that in your voice
oh gosh I'm I'm shocked yeah and you
feel blessed and that's a good that's a
good position to be emotionally now what
I want that to lead you to do is instead
of letting that lead you to be sloppy I
want it I want you to feel the weight of
the responsibility of that kind of money
um and which is kind of the opposite end
of the spectrum of Redneck Rich
okay
yes sir and so that's going to involve
like I'm going to start treating this
very very seriously like I'm a rich guy
because you are okay and now I've got a
now what is the smartest thing I can do
so that when this story is over you have
20 million dollars
and if you'll behave and and have a nice
life I'm not talking about living a cave
and collect lint but I'm talking about
you know just behave and and be diligent
and intentional with every one of these
dollars you you easily could have 20
million dollars when this story's
finished
okay but you're gonna have to just do
all I want you to do is just do
everything on purpose instead of waking
up with a financial hangover when this
is over
I I totally understand my question would
have you know yeah and that means pay
off these cars and turn around and pay
this house off you make 400k act like
you make a hundred and let's clear a
bunch of this debt and you're sitting
there with paid for cars paid for a
house now there's nothing left to do but
incredible generosity enjoy life and
invest for the future
I like that and you can do all three
beautifully and I'm talking like 36
months from now
I think that sounds great yeah that
makes me smile thinking about it you
know but that means you're not going to
be living like you've been living for
the past two years oh well honestly I
ran out of stuff to buy I mean I can
tell
Dave
I I listen to you you know on and off
especially before I had a business I I
made about 55 000 a year my wife's made
about the same as what she made and I
took a risk open my business and it is
so we're talking about let's just use
some round numbers just to wrap this up
okay here's what I'm doing in my head
for you all right I'm hearing 450
and 400 on the house and 100 on cars did
I hear that right 450 income
that's it okay and so if you lived on
100 that'd be 350 not counting taxes
yeah and that pays off a hundred
thousand dollars worth of cars really
really fast you got some money in the
bank we already paid off some today and
and then it's going to pay off the rest
um
you know you're not gonna knock that
house out I'm telling you 36 months is
doable can you see that oh I understand
my question was with with you know the
recession with the I don't have any idea
what that's going to do to your business
that's why I was asking you about that
if you think the recession is going to
slow down so much you're not going to
get the concrete work and it's going to
go down to 220. so what keep living on
100 and it slows down how fast you get
the house paid off whoop-dee-doopy house
is still going to be paid for in under
four years and you're still young and
you still have tremendous upside
potential on this income he's in a Sweet
Spot yeah he's gonna crush it but you
know I'd get out of that I think the
question is does he want to get out of
that arm quickly or just pay it off
before the arm runs out I just pay it
off yeah so there's your answer you know
you pay it off for it you if you're
going to take 10 years to pay it off go
get it refinanced but you're not you
shouldn't if you do this irresponsible
because you make so stinking much money
clean it up man clean it up you'll be
glad you did you'll be glad you leaned
into this and made this a project treat
it like you're manager in a country
project knock it out get her done